there's so many variables in cooking
it's always about time and temperature
any recipe that you read is going to
talk about how long to cook something at
what temperature to cook something
remember they're only guidelines it's
really about being able to appreciate
the technique and the process and work
with it
if you make a mistake it's okay before
you know it you'll know
how to roast a beautiful chicken pan
roast a duck breast with
crispy skin or any things that we've
been teaching
let's get started young culinarians ask
me all the time
if i can give them some words of wisdom
and i always give them too
be patient and then be persistent don't
let anybody tell you you can't do
something
you can what flavor do you really want
in your vegetables or meats
it's really up to you don't take
anything as a rule
in this master class i'm very excited to
elevate your cooking abilities
super tender look at this dinner
i love this kind of cooking to see it to
smell it the experience that they hear
it
it truly is transformational and it
requires
a really a commitment in time but if you
want to make great food
this is what you have to do and remember
patience patience
patience
oh look at that
i want you to think about what you want
to be eating
there are so many flavors textures
techniques and recipes
simple perfection i'm thomas keller
and this is my masterclass
you